votre discours je ne l'acceptent plus
comme des millions de français qui se
faufile dans les rues qui se retrouve en
cachette jeunes obéirait plus je ne
reconnais plus votre autorité
nous n'allons plus attendre votre
permission
[Musique]
on ne sait pas de quel côté va retomber
la pièce mais la pièce c'est nous c'est
la france c'est 67 millions de citoyens
le citoyen libre avec liberté même comme
premiers mots de notre devise
après un confinement à déconfinement 1re
confinement 1re déconfinement un
couvre-feu à 19h un couvre-feu à 10 à 18
heures nous voilà va conclure
confinement territoriale partiellement
des confiné et un couvre-feu à 19 heures
avec attestation de sortie mais
finalement semble finalement si c'est du
colmatage du rafistolage sans aucune
stratégie sans aucun calendrier des
d'ekwa des délits commencé à delhi le
premier ministre aux mêmes et c'est à ça
qu'on le reconnaît il ose même un les
soignants ne mentent pas d'augmenter le
nombre de lits à l'hôpital
eh bien s'ils le demandent et même il
s'étonne je les cite
nous sommes le seul pays au monde à
fermer des lits en pleine pandémie
allons allons le répétons à quoi
servirait des lices en soignant son
personnel
[Musique]
et sur les vaccins c'est pire presque
combien de doses seront produites en
france en mars 0 combien en avril 0
combien en mai 0 combien de tout le
temps de tout l'été 00 souveraineté
gouvernement attendent les doses les
doses qu'ils ne viennent pas que pfizer
ou médard navale vient de livrer et sans
même réclamé pour les français la levée
des brevets à l'om c'est alors comme la
digue ne tient plus comme la digue ne
viennent pas soir que faire fermer
robinet le robinet des libertés voilà
votre variable d'ajustement est toujours
toujours au nom des soignants mais ça ne
prend plus
[Musique]